have you ever done something really
stupid with money if you're over 12 you
should have raised your hand just then
all of us have
some of us is more of a public display
of stupidity some of you are able to
hide it and isn't it amazing when
everything's going good when the economy
is going good the job's going good the
marriage is going good everything's
going good stupid doesn't it you can
cover stupid you can actually make
stupid look like you're doing something
good like you buy a car you can't afford
and everybody thinks you're making it
look at George George is doing good did
you see that car he bought that job must
be kicking it all George got was a
payment coming out of his freaking ear
holes